gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the
are you garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're gonna be coming to a
town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
gonna be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know
july 14th columbus funny bone july 15
cleveland hilarities august 11th rhode
island comedy connection
august 12th left boston those tickets
are cooking that's gonna sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at mcgooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's gonna be a
fantastic fun time a mix of stand-up
comedy in the ayg game
come out and hang with uncle hank and
your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we found out if they grow up to be
classy
or just a big old piece of trash or
thing i'm your host h foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
at auntie's basement
i saw her upstairs while i was up there
getting a cup of coffee
oh yeah what's he up to she was woofing
down a subway sandwich
and if you've seen that woman eat i
don't know where she puts it but
my god uh she wanted me to ask you
about uh gas cards you know anything
about this
gas cards corporate account gas card or
like a prepaid gas card
yeah prepaid gas card she she wanted to
know if you can get your hands on a
couple
because she thinks she can make a couple
uh she wants to contribute to the to the
business and she thinks she can sell
some gas cards and she figured you would
know
because you got all this stuff going on
i don't know nothing about no gas cards
all right i'll tell her she's not gonna
be happy uh well if she wants gas cards
she can call me directly
i don't know why she hasn't been talking
to me and i don't know why she's not
gonna call in
this isn't the thing you call on the
phone okay you meet outside and talk
on a bench looking the other way okay
gang my co-host is coming at you from
across the table this is a family
episode it's just the gang just the
squad
just the way we like it we love you um
he's the ceo of are you garbage
he's kind of the head bozo around here
so uh show the guy a little respect will
you
all right knock it off with the toilet
paper at his house in the trees he's a
good kid
when you're reaching for a best pal do
yourself a [ __ ] favor
and make it a kippy because it comes
with a couple of zeros behind
kevin james ryan everybody batman's
sitting pretty this week
a little hemmed up yesterday wasn't a
banking day if you catch my drift
you'll be getting presents from my whole
family yeah i [ __ ] better this
this thing better start paying dividends
on my end
i got all the foley's laughing all the
way to the bank
turkey my mom's making you for
thanksgiving it's gonna knock your socks
off
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true the roof
true the [ __ ] roof baby oh yeah
uh we're closing in on like 22 or 23
000. closing it on 22
000 next goal is 25 baby get that to 25k
if you listen just go subscribe to the
youtube help the boys out
juice those numbers a bit uh and then
obviously patreon.com which i mean
that thing's got a [ __ ] motor on that
thing might be a hemi on that thing i
don't know who the programming director
is over there but it's [ __ ]
must-see tv yeah i'll tell you that
there's so much [ __ ] content on the
patreon
it's [ __ ] nuts i mean we're posting
you know 10-minute clips of the live
shows that we're doing are on there only
available on there
uh i mean you get hard feelings you get
bonus episodes at ayg we have
your first limo ride we have the cribs
tour of my
childhood house your childhood house the
whole [ __ ] nine yards i mean we
played ayg with our [ __ ] parent with
our moms
we did the [ __ ] milk with dinner
taste test he did the sats which i
forgot about
which i think toby's the dumbest one in
the room which don't make me too
confident
uh yeah guys thanks for all this [ __ ]
support we love yous and how about that
producer extraordinaire he's a queen's
native he just took his like 22 hours
just
took a city test last night oh yeah yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be a bus driver
good bennies good bennies look at you're
gonna start hanging at the local irish
bar
knock up some bartender you'll be out
there in queens like archie bunker
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin it's toby
mcmullen everybody
what's up dudes what's up buddy nothing
man just got my
neighbors outside in the back shirtless
sweating dude
dude it's queens queens is a little bit
hotter than the rest of the city
queen's in august is that tough oh man
i hope you like graffiti and fireworks
gang it's a family episode we're here
uh kippy had a little extravaganza this
weekend he was at
i was at our friend paul verzi's yes you
were you juice
who as we know is a classy guy and he
holds the
ambassador of class he's been on the
show twice he holds this annual fourth
of july part
which was just you know the other night
not a bad piece of property he's got up
there
neither that guy's on top of the hill i
think he's top of the hill he's got the
high deck i felt like i was in
switzerland that we were like doing that
switch back to get up
he lives up there baby nice house
beautiful piece of property
i gotta tell you they throw the [ __ ]
down but this is a thing
he's like uh so this is my first like
adult party i'm going to
with a little bit of cash right with a
little bit of where your family's not
involved where my family's not involved
right and like you don't get your mom to
go to to [ __ ] yo
break me off 100 for the bar and this is
a party i feel that you
bring something you can't show up
empty-handed at a versi party you can't
do it
i wouldn't show i wouldn't walk up to
his car without him or something
you kidding me this guy's classy because
you know if he showed up at your joint
he's going to have a little something
with him of course yeah of course he's
going to put an addition on your house
you want a diving board or a sliding
board you choose
so i didn't know what to do so i'm this
i'm not i and like
this brought up so much [ __ ] in me from
being a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] for the
past
you know whatever 15 years i've never
given anybody a good gift
anytime i'm giving a gift i'm
self-conscious because i'm like i'm
they're going to be like your wife won't
put her purse down
people don't know how to act so
i never know what are all these foods
free what's going on
i never know what to do so i'm like this
one's on the line i gotta come [ __ ]
heavy bike i gotta come correct
and i got kcb our last guest texting me
what are you bringing what do you get
you know what are you doing ain't gonna
be a bag of tostitos
yeah so i go you can't go so i even i
even
i [ __ ] hit up yanny i go i need some
[ __ ] intel
i go yanny what's mr verzee like to what
kind of wines he like
if he's got the scoops and some medium
salsa
i brought the queso that's a bar that's
a party stopper
the queso is a showstopper yo toss this
in the microwave real quick
i wanna put a pin in the in the story i
remember the first time i had that salsa
cone queso
oh come on shout out to the stunsky's
house and like [ __ ] 98.
blew my hair those boys in the tostitos
lab weren't screwing around i'll tell
you that
those guys were working overtime racking
their brains come heavy or don't come at
all
that is the [ __ ] sausage on queso
somebody stormed into a board meeting
like stop i got it
right holy [ __ ] their spinach dip ain't
nothing to shake a stick out
i don't know about all that but i'm
[ __ ] it's nice i say it i stay south
of the border
that's right that sounds like canadian
[ __ ] to me
i go south okay you and the canucks can
have the [ __ ] spinach
i'm down here in a sombrero partying
i remember kasich called kids i bought
my boy pat we were drunk
and we got back to his crib at night
like in like i don't know high school or
whatever
i mean i heat it up i that wasn't a
thing i didn't oh
jar right in the microwave that's what
he did he give it a little stir
what's the hell what's that all about
what's that thing you got over there
dude hey where's the taco truck huh
dude i pulled one [ __ ] in one little
[ __ ] corner of a toast just to
[ __ ] wet my whistle a bit and get my
bearings
whoa yeah it's like two weeks vacation
that's advice
dude that's a game changer
out to we gotta get a jar for the
[ __ ] cello uh
for the house yeah so and then my mom
started buying i don't know this goes
back to a thing i don't know if it was
just never on my radar it was just
always in the fridge and i never [ __ ]
with it
but once i knew it it's like then there
was a couple of things that
uh when they hit and your mom discovered
it
it was now a staple and everybody loved
it for us it was those snyder's
broken um honey mustard and onion uh
pretzels
yeah when we found those things it was
like we discovered [ __ ]
i can't [ __ ] those eldorados those
things are like radioactive to me
they got a weird scent a weird color
they're barely giving you broken
pretzels
buddy i'm paying full price for the bag
how about a little [ __ ] out of full prep
that was when we found out about honey
roasted peanuts that was a game changer
you brought like the planters
we had no idea foleys were never the
same
took out a second mortgage [ __ ]
planner's truck backing up
how do you think the peanut butt that
monocle
it's all foley money you put the paint
you put [ __ ] mr penis kids through
college
skip a university okay um
so i got to be honest i'm sweating this
gift a little bit sure so i hit up yanny
i go yo
what's [ __ ] versey what kind of rat
what kind of wines versi like
he was like a nice cab whatever then i
went back and listened to his episode
because i know he mentioned a couple of
[ __ ] wines
you two started throwing stags revenge
or something stag sleep
stags leap the place in my neighborhood
didn't have it no but it had a very
there is a place in my neighborhood this
top shelf like i don't belong in there
like it's sure that's most places for me
so so um check your w-2s on the way in
i have an incomplete w-9 sorry we cannot
like
from 40 years ago still trying to get
still trying to get my head back
so i don't know what to do i'm panicking
you know i want to come correct he's
also helped me out a lot personally in
standup used to take me on the road with
him sure it's more of like a
a gesture you know i i want to [ __ ] i
want to i want to come correct that's
what i want to do
um solid gold telephone
get him a shark watch i just bought two
shark watches this weekend oh man this
guy's gonna be under water all summer
goes in the dark underwater
so uh i
i can't i can't have an above ground
pool and an underwater watch
let's see this guy's topsy turvy over
here
got a space pen he can ride upside down
this guy's ready for anything
we have to keep him guessing part the
cars behind the garage
oh man that's funny so i ended up
i get nervous in the wine place i don't
even i don't have confidence
i'm like googling the wine thing to make
sure it was the right thing in the world
blind's not my forte if it ain't he
should have called me
well you said i you said you bought a
battle of stag sleep i listened in our
episode
a bottle i was gonna say a bag a bottle
so i end up
so i go you know what this is [ __ ] uh
you can only
i think it's easier to go wrong with a
bottle of wine right
i mean not really i mean well he also
said he goes you can go to every remove
no doubt you remove all data that's
you did that anyway that's what i wanted
no doubt i wanted i'm coming [ __ ]
correct
well you did that kippy's at the party
you did that i got a bottle of
log of woolen i don't even know how to
pronounce it
something 16. what the high numbers
16. 16 alcohol they had a 12 i said
kick rocks with the 12 a three don't
even look at me no
lag lag of woolen 16 that's his he goes
if i'm blowing it out like if i'm like
really going like he's got it on the
road a couple of times
top shelf hundred bucks a bottle hundred
bucks
it wasn't a little bit more one-on-one
108 with dax all right they got me in
manhattan they get you yeah
so something like that a johnny walker
blue
but he said he said he's like that's
mine if i'm blowing it out i'll get a
bottle of that
come and we'll go we'll go at it i feel
like johnny walker though no matter
which one you get is like a
is like someone who doesn't know about
liquor but wants to buy an expensive
look yeah sure
i wanted to come in like subtle like
i've heard you talk about there you go
bully
pretty classy so not a jew you didn't
you didn't do the
the rookie mistake of just putting on a
table you handed that to him i would
hope well listen this is the story
so that's a hander yeah i'm not [ __ ]
letting that get mixed in with the
[ __ ] bottles of schmearnoff get the
[ __ ] out of here
oh something i made them come out to the
car to get it all of a sudden they're
making mixed drinks with it what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] 32 dollar shot you're taking
uh no so i'm out to the car to the trunk
so i'm feeling it so then i was i i
i've never felt confident giving a gift
and now that's like a new feeling for me
so i'm like am i got to feel confident
given that i did so i go up so
he's actually out front when we're
pulling up like he's somebody's kind
of he's out front so ugly like we're
walking down beautiful piece of property
that verzi's got
he's walking down the driveway and he
goes yo kid what's up comes out and
meets house like in the front yard you
know dap them up i go yo this is for you
in the box it comes in a box not just a
bottle
you get a box with this thing i've never
bought i mean i bought wine in a box but
that was the actual
this is the bottle came in a box
um you ever give some one of those wood
boxes those
come on i mean what are we doing that's
right from john jamison
[Laughter]
barrel whiskey went overboard it's
private stock
kept it up in his room under his bed
he's gonna talk about a headstack
so i go here you go and like i hand it
to he hugs me
hugs my wife here you go oh [ __ ]
whoa he goes oh damn [ __ ] thank you so
much
and then i knew it hit him because we
take a couple of steps there's nine
other bottles
he's using it to start the grill
but i hit him with it and he goes oh
thank you like you go oh [ __ ] thanks you
know
and then we took a couple of steps like
walking towards the house and i think it
hit him and he goes
hey good he turns onto my left i mean is
this guy [ __ ] classier is this guy
[ __ ]
yeah man i was like well i'm coming i
gotta come correct here baby
if i'm coming correct anywhere i'm
coming correct here [ __ ] my parents
i gotta impress mr mercy then you pull
out the buffalo dip
keep it real got the cone queso on me
bam
where's the microwave at i always
thought it was a tough looking people
showed up with like you know potluck
stuff and they have the tin foil over
top get a top today
come on i mean if you're going to like i
think that's fine if i like you know
it might just might be because i'm a
cousin if i'm going to like my [ __ ]
aunt paddy's house or something
that's fine because it's so you're not
you're not putting on presentations to
you're like immediately super fast if
you show up and there's probably
something banging in there too
yeah if you show up tonight taco dude
met a corn chip it didn't like it dude
it's like
it's like a big [ __ ] circle tray
dude out on christmas eve
[Laughter]
ho ho
um wait a minute so let's say let's say
this is a [ __ ] doozy let's say in
some instance sure
all right you did bring something all
right
like uh you brought we brought some
dessert or whatever
yeah all right which i was kicking
around no he doesn't want
he's got his what some regular bozo
that's also the thing you can't show up
diversity's like that you're [ __ ] up
with she you know she has a
vision i know i don't want you bringing
it i was like yo what time tomorrow
three he's like yeah i'm like can i
bring anything is it nah yeah
i was like yeah well you gotta show up
with a [ __ ] 11 krispy kreme
i got munchkins whose birthday is it
i think i just killed you i've never
seen you react like
dude i've been picking at him on the
ride up
bringing munchkins man is such a trash
unless it's early in the morning they're
the only time munchkins should be making
an appearance
what are munchkins what the [ __ ]
you want to be my producer you know what
a [ __ ] munchkin is they're
donut holes yeah they're donut holes oh
duncan
made to perfection by one of the true
artists of all time
joe duncan joey dave joey d
kills you get a fresh one of those
things good night um whoa
yeah i just want to say that that was
the first time i felt good giving a gift
and
it felt nice to give it to him nice he
was so
classy yeah you know who's a very you
know yeah yeah yeah fella felt really
good
i gotta say by the way he [ __ ] souped
and nuts that party was
i saw it they must have set up about 35k
worth of [ __ ] fireworks
proper like music cues [ __ ]
real horse bangle banner rachel do you
have anybody working it with him because
that's what i was wondering do you have
a couple of guys really yeah a couple of
guys that weren't at the party
no we didn't have a crew coming in
they're all missing fingers and
he's like fireworks guys are here he's
dressed like danny mcbride
um no it's awesome like it's like a
thing now it's like
the crew's there got it like you know
there's a couple of neighbors got a
couple of regulars stuff like that
gotcha that's a home run [ __ ] foo
everything was
i can imagine great good job buddy good
job felt real
i felt like it i felt like in a i drove
my 2021 lease kia up there
god yeah i felt i was like i'm doing
like i'm not meeting my parents no
nothing
kippy's back baby try to keep a good man
down
ah that's good my question was sure if
you go to somebody's
house and you have like a baking dish or
whatever
do you wait and take it with you or do
you just let that slide
personally what would you do i just keep
i don't want it i [ __ ] i want my dirty
dishes back
no yeah that stuff to me is like i'll
buy a new one really yeah i don't care
the piece was just leaving [ __ ] no
she probably wasn't
that happened all the time like i would
go to my you know i'd go to my aunt
i'll bring his back give this to your
mother it's from easter
i was like a [ __ ] tupperware hey
honey when i work for a catering company
[ __ ] the cash talks let's go came
here
with the green ah it's fantastic
i love it it was great how was your i
don't think yours was as
star-studded there was no lagavulin
[Music]
it's shotgunned a couple of [ __ ] paps
but i woke up i had [ __ ] uh
it's eight racks of ribs that i was
responsible for went out to the [ __ ]
you had to eat all eight of them
[Laughter]
my i told you about hey it rules the
rules
[Laughter]
traditions it's holy the fourth of july
the fattest guy has the
eight racks of ribs um no i had to
i i had responsible for eight racks of
ribs and [ __ ] i go out in the morning
traeger's not working starter wasn't
going couldn't get the fire going
what'd you do called an audible i
[ __ ] put them in the microwave
now we did them in the oven for four
hours slow cooked and then i finished
them on the grill
the only thing that saved me was the
sauce took a little bit of [ __ ]
barbecue sauce some german mustard
and the drippings from uh the pan inside
where i did the
ribs put it in an iv
picked some smoothies while we waited a
couple
appetizers for the boys huh something to
take the edge off
yeah good [ __ ] nice helix
sleep yeah kippy the best in the
beginning you know firsthand you're
laying on one of those bad boys every
night
yes a lot of people have trouble
sleeping these days even more so
than in uh you know in the past yeah you
got the pandemic pandemic people are
stressed out they got a
you know they got a lumpy mattress they
have a soft mattress their partner
sleeps weird
this that the other thing helix takes
all that
out of the equation because you take a
quiz before you buy the mattress yeah
they got them for everybody they even
got big boy ones
for guys like uncle hank yeah and a lot
of our listeners who were the big boys
fair enough you can get a nice night's
sleep
with helix uh me and my wife took the
quiz the sleep quiz it takes like two
minutes
you hop online answer a couple of
questions bing bang boom
they uh they match you with the best
matches for you
and their whole thing is like why would
you get a mattress for somebody why
would you get a mattress designed for
somebody else exactly and also who the
hell wants to be
going mattress shopping in the middle of
a pandemic sleeping on a bed with
someone
we don't do that no more come on i don't
know if you know we don't do that no
more
no studying take the quiz we got the
twilight mattress
uh we that's what was recommended for us
and it's fantastic
it gets shipped to your house you open
it up easy peasy
it pops up you know comes all folded up
in a little box
it's crazy how they [ __ ] that's insane
crazy i must have a
strong guy at the shipping department
just crunching them things in you pop it
open in like two hours you can sleep on
it's fantastic yeah it's good stuff best
sleep in my life i'm thinking of even
upgrading to a king size
really i'm thinking about it we're
thinking about pulling the trigger on a
king too and it's definitely going to be
helix
if we do it yeah uh so if you're looking
for a mattress take the quiz order the
mattress that's matched to you and it
comes right to your door
shipped free you don't ever have to go
to the metro store again uh it's awesome
but why take our word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick
of 2020 by gq and wired magazine baby
a couple of serious publications right
there not bozos just
go mad magazine again helix is offering
up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
up to 200 that's free money babe what
are we doing you can't afford not to buy
this mattress
get on it ah that's helixsleep.com
garbage
one more time guys helixsleep.com
garbage for up to 200
off and two free pillows oh baby do it
gang let's talk about ladder
oh yeah over here with antooties you
know the older i get the more i start
thinking about certain things about your
family
uh what you want to leave them this
stuff matters put them into a position
to put them in a bad spot after you go
it's why a lot of people are considering
life insurance these days
sure are a lot of them are looking to
term life yeah and you need to look no
further
than ladder yeah guys uh ladder is 100
digital
uh there's no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply
for three million in coverage or less
wow
yeah i'm what are we talking about here
you just need a few minutes uh
and a phone a laptop to apply ladders
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find
instantly if you're approved they're not
got time to be waiting around you've got
stuff to do
circle the wagons take care of everybody
but if you do prefer to talk to a person
their team of licensed agents doesn't
work on commission so they'll help you
they'll so they'll help you and not
upsell you see i like that i like to not
working on commissions they
they're doing it you know they're making
money they're doing their thing
but but they're there to help they're
there to help there's no hidden fees you
can cancel at any time get a full refund
if you change your mind within the first
30 days but why would you
uh and latter policies are issued by
insurers with long proven histories of
paying claims
they're a rated and a plus by am best
wow not sure what that means but it
sounds sounds fantastic legit
finally since life insurance cost more
at your age now's the time
to cross it off your list because the
older they get the more expensive it
gives you sure you're more voluntary
move now take care of it there you go uh
so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage gang this
podcast is sponsored by better
help self-care something everybody's
doing these days
very important mental health very the
most important i would say
and we're out of this stigma where you
know
getting help or needing help or needing
help or whatever not a sign of weakness
or nothing
and let me tell you something the people
at better health are absolutely
fantastic the best
they don't just dish out pills they
don't just do this they don't just do
that
they lock you in with a licensed
therapist
you get talking to them within 48 hours
about anything almost in all 50 states
yep unbelievable yeah guys it's
fantastic
uh if you've never tried talk therapy it
it really helped me and my personal life
a lot it's helped you
i know um especially if you're trying to
achieve something if you're working
towards something like
you know trying to make it in comedy and
stuff like that it really helps to have
something to bounce off people you know
what i mean take inventory of your life
your family your friends all the whole
nine yards and you can do it in the
privacy of your own home yeah you don't
have to go wait sitting
you know sitting uh in a waiting room
reading old magazines hearing bozo's cry
you're crying it's a mess you can do
this at home it's easy peasy you log in
from your account anytime
send a message to your counsel you'll
get timely thoughtful responses
um betterhelp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free of charge
to change counselors if you need to
love it you know what i mean it's easy
peasy uh it's more affordable and
traditional than offline counseling and
financial aid is available
if you need it look at that um
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today and so does kippy and
uncle
that's right why not be happy i like
that how do you really like these guys
you're here for one time what are we
doing you know what i mean there's no
one to better help gang
no redos in this enjoy it uh you can
visit their website and
listen to their testimonials uh but
visit betterhealth.com
garbage that's betterhelp h-e-l-p and
join over 1 million people who have
taken change of their mental health
uh with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they're now
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states look at that i mean what are
we doing i said that they're everywhere
these are all over the place special
offer for ayg listeners you'll get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage 10 off the whole month
thank you 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
garbage now back to the show all right
gang it is a family episode as we said
we were gonna read off some of your
patreon questions here
sure thing yes sir kippy's at the helm
toby's on the ones and twos what do you
got before we dive in
uh we just announced our next patreon
goal once we hit 2100 we're gonna do the
inaugural ayg
invitational sure throw the irons around
yeah on a golf course
on the golf course now this this brings
up a couple of questions
how are we going to get on a golf course
what do you mean can't do public
yeah you can what are we bozos come on
private's not going to let
us on by the way yeah just because we
got to go can't golf on a private course
in mesh shorts foley okay
can't be wearing flip-flops in a tee box
i can assimilate with these people
give the starter [ __ ] kiss bottle of
scotch
[Laughter]
all right so i want to put this out if
you're in the you know relative
tri-state area hour drive or so let's
call it
and you work at a course or can get us
on a course okay
grassroots are like this it would
probably have to be like a tuesday night
or something we can go out and do it
you know weekends are [ __ ] because
you also don't want some
we don't well we don't want someone up
our ass no it's me we're gonna be
playing a little bit
we're gonna bring some family on some
some of the company on yeah maybe
you know a guest find out who else
please go you know who [ __ ] messaged
me which i didn't tell
either one of you that goes i want in mr
j
larson goes i want in on this
wow said buddy open invite love that
yeah
he's a proper probably works for the
golf channel yeah
yeah pretty sweet so uh we got to find
out a place to do it
i did google worst courses in new jersey
and something came up so maybe we'll do
it there
uh as long as the software machine's on
that [ __ ] cart that beverage carts
making around that's all i care about
and so we announced this and then we got
a home run comment i want to shout out
on the pod
get it this thing is excellent this is
from uh
mccutcheon phil a garbage golf bag
includes
and this to me is a definitive list this
guy put it in the [ __ ] parking lot
a decent driver some 40 year old 3-wood
you found in your uncle's basement after
his house got foreclosed on of course no
one uses a 3-wood continue
an assortment of irons at least two
different brands and bonus points for
any duplicates
like two different seminars i don't know
whatever that means but it sounds funny
this all checks out on my bag by the way
some illegal wedge but you have a golf
bag
yeah man oh god who are you did you just
buy it
you have a tv in it it's got a cooler
start it's got a radio antenna comes out
some illegal wedge you got from kmart
that you've hit exactly one good shot
with in three years but you still bust
out every time you're 80 and in that's
pretty good a wilson putter
and this is the and this is just the
home run a couple extra big
side pockets for some screaming cold
highlifes yeah that's what you do
i don't know about all this this heist
is so i'm coming for the working man i'm
[ __ ] borrowing clubs i'm bringing
three and i'm gonna [ __ ] shut it down
pay that right now
well this is this raises the quest i
want to do it on i didn't know you had a
golf bag yeah i'm not a [ __ ]
holly's gonna play the whole course like
with a seven iron like in ten cups
you're [ __ ] doing the pool cue
hitting it in you got cheech marin with
me
i think i can make it
[Laughter]
lane's rich kid you got a golf bag i
worked at a golf course
nice yeah and we golfed in high school
we golfed a lot
really yeah yeah yeah golfed in high
school i worked at a golf course you
know
i guess i'll give you that uh yeah i
don't know it's just like [ __ ]
something
a lot of kids golf you know okay
i like golf i'm looking forward to busy
yeah
well like my thing is like are we
getting the cart
well this raises we would probably only
do nine holes i don't think we can you
know
a full eighteen i'll do it i'll do fully
with the cart
i ain't walking all around this place
she's got my nice shirt on but can you
drive a golf ball
yeah to drive don't answer me like i'm a
[ __ ] jerk
i can drive a golf cart so yeah we'll
have to figure we'll have to figure out
the logistics of it but yeah sure yeah
yeah
i have to be some training sessions i'll
have to go over the [ __ ] chelsea
piers
and hit a couple no because we're
putting money on who wins so what do you
not want to see
each other what are you minnesota fats
what's going on
what are you blue belt that's what it's
shooter mcgavin over here
oh yeah but we'll figure it out sabotage
me on the course we'll figure out all
the
all of the details yeah it's going to be
awesome um that
being said uh it is a fan map we get
into some [ __ ]
home run questions we got cooking here
home
run [ __ ] questions this one speaking
of liquor
company parties this one's from tommy h
ever disguise booze i like to buy a 750
milliliter bottle of baileys
pricey the handle of cheap irish cream
and at parties i fill it up and no one's
none the wiser
i don't so he he's bought one bottle of
bailey's
yes uses it yeah it's empty he then
refills it with cheap [ __ ] when people
come over
and passes it off as bailey's is he
moving that much baileys
that's a big bailey's crown what the
[ __ ]
putting it in his cereal there's one
aunt that drinks bailey's that's it
um yeah that's i mean this chili's is
great
billy's is fantastic yeah i'm sure on
the holidays we do nutty irishmen of
course you do
i also have the drink not the irishman
is like amaretto
[ __ ] something else and bailey's i
think i never understood and i'm not i'm
not [ __ ] on this guy because i have
a couple of friends that are really
some people are like i think weird about
liquor
about like [ __ ] like the good stuff into
this and who gives a
[ __ ] dude i'll drink whatever you're
filling bottles
like come on i mean that's garbage yeah
someone wants a little irish
cream in their coffee you know it is
what it is like we'll take whatever you
got
and i don't i wouldn't i don't
understand the reason of standing on air
is to be like oh yeah it's bailey's who
gives the stuff it's
the other [ __ ] yeah i mean you're mixing
with something yeah even if you're
drinking it straight
put in coffee come on let's go dude
there's no way the ryans are [ __ ]
doing all this for a nutty irishman what
is it two cups
no you don't do that you you're not a
[ __ ] irish bar on [ __ ] st
patrick's day it's [ __ ] coffee and
booze they're calling it nutty irish no
there's no
place so they sound so they don't sound
like psychos there's no coffee
whatever's in it first ingredient
going over what no i don't think we do
coffee and a nutty iron yeah cause
you're boozers
i know we mix they're not putting the
creme de mint and whipped cream on top
they're throwing a chicken finger in
there and slugging it down
then get into a fight over money
it's frangelico all right yeah
frangelico
i give he's feeling himself i love it
angelico golf
that's so funny like no coffee in it
first ingredient strong coffee
and then irish cream frangelico hazelnut
liquor
and irish cream that's what it is it's
frangelica and
uh frangelico and
[ __ ] baileys and you poured over a
spoon or whatever well
you're not doing it with a little bit of
ice the recipe the recipe i'm looking at
does have four and a half stars and four
ratings so it might be a little wonky
well listen i don't know
i'm telling you what it is there ain't
no call blue ice gatorade
shot of baileys um but anyway
yeah were you ever a long island iced
tea guy no
i always thought there was iced tea in
it
to be honest with you i was trying to
watch my sugar intake
[ __ ] i want a nice teeth give me a beer
like a [ __ ] gentleman yeah
no we're we're not long island adults
adults
who drink long island iced teas are
the trashiest man yeah if you're
anywhere and you're like hey you gotta
get a long island i see they don't have
food because
if that doesn't send up a red flag
i don't know what does yeah anybody
anybody here orders all of the long
island iced tea that's insanely poop
i'm gonna get one of those little stars
over there i remember one time this dude
down the shore there was this one i
forget she was like a family friend it
was a woman
she's like yeah we were out there i had
three mind erasers i was like yo
you can't be doing mind erasers with
kids
that's [ __ ] bad news three mind
erasers and hit shotgun falls
yeah like dude talk about doing a hard
system reboot that the three mind
erasers
shut your [ __ ] down it's like something
the lawyer tells you you had a mind
eraser
yeah holy cow yeah mind eraser
fuzzy navel sex on the beach
lemon drop lemon juice
hold on here jerkball [ __ ] elliott
ness over here
take it easy prohibition paul huh trying
to [ __ ] wet our whistle here it says
american god damn it
this [ __ ] scumbag comes out of
nowhere [ __ ] on a lemon drop
what a lemon drop ever hurt
[Laughter]
sounds like something personal
trying to get the party going a couple
lemon drops little sugar rim
whoa man mean none might get some of
them on the way out of here throwing
some pyt we got a night going
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] hates a lemon
i mean i don't love them but i got
nothing wrong with them [ __ ]
that's fantastic next you know they're
coming for the ipas
yeah they took our lemon drops we said
nothing
and now they want our ipas over my cold
dead body
oh god fantastic home run this one's
from tony p as a miner were you allowed
to post nudity on your walls
as if you were your parents stunk holy
[ __ ]
those walls had holes in them like yeah
for sure the kid with a couple of holes
punched in his room yeah that went
un un run re-drywalled i knew
i mean i knew if i punched a hole in our
wall it was
gonna be a thing sure it wasn't just
ending it like
you gotta fix though it had to be a
major blowout it would have to be
a big sunday night foley [ __ ]
wrestlemania throwdown
had to be something big real big yeah
me and my brother going at it like a
building all weekend
then it explodes and i'm in my room
punch the hole in the door dad comes in
what do i do
yeah no we never that would be my
[ __ ] head would be through a wall
no [ __ ] way no way never
i knew enough to not those linoleum
doors when thought i was a kid man
linoleum linoleum yeah that's what it is
luon i'm sorry luan
yeah linoleum what's that like
that's that's how trashy you are you
think the linoleum
is like plastic it made the look i know
yeah
which i was like maybe he did have
linoleum doors who knows what the [ __ ]
going on in that house
i mean like yeah like kitchen the
kitchen's in the 80s and 90s
i'm thinking of luan those cheap blue on
wood doors yeah like
they're hollow yeah yeah yeah connect
everything
anything like that had to be hidden it
was hidden away
what the nudity putting [ __ ] like a t
i mean
i knew some kids that were able to get
like the uh
whatever our version of the britney
spears posters we did that i
i was allowed tony katane whoever it was
back when i was like pamela anderson
you get her in a bikini maybe yeah so
yeah like the sports illustrated had the
poster or whatever oh
yeah i was allowed those but like 18 and
it was kind of like
those sports illustrated swimsuits
issues when i was a kid before you know
oh my god kathy ireland the works man i
don't know
more of a nancy scottish kind of guy
i don't know what beach they were at or
nothing you could go to
i don't know i don't know where in
jersey they were
[Laughter]
get him coming right out of the water
whoo that was almost better
because there was a little imagination
yeah yeah yeah but then eventually you
get old enough
sure that just won't do yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um no no no no no no nudies
no on the walls i remember i think i'm
sure i've said this at some point
uh my my stepdads had like a car shop
and like we're like other guys sure sure
yeah oh the calendars come on
yeah and they had yeah they had some
cutouts on like one of those snap-on
[ __ ] three laps around the sand
grinder huh yeah what's over here what's
back over this way what's going on over
there where's the bat
again try to memorize it like [ __ ]
john nash get it burned in here
i can yeah i still pick and the one
there was a they had a
in the one like pickup truck or whatever
there was a
an air freshener with a lady in a yellow
string bikini
really yeah i don't know what she's up
to nowadays but
she lived in my mind for quite some time
talking about rent-free
yeah usually what what would be the
situation is because
it was never just that it was never just
a friend that was able to have
nudie posters on his wall there was a
whole other
you know there was so much that came
with it there was never just that one
thing
there was holes in the walls the mom
didn't clean you were allowed to
skateboard in the backyard like that's
the kid that
sure built like a half pipe back there
that's so funny you bring that up i
would that i wrote that down hundred
percent ayg
it's never a half pipe was bad news oh
my god
in the backyard yeah but with stolen
construction wood
was that was that i stole yeah that was
so bad news
yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 i remember i
asked him like can we have a hat because
some kid on my
kid like a couple years older than i
mean like the bad you know the shittier
area had one
cover with like big blue tarps it was a
talk about an eyesore yeah
i didn't get it as a kid yeah but now
i'm looking at my parents like get the
[ __ ]
property value have all these kids they
have all these tobys hanging around yeah
no [ __ ] i'll say this though that mom
the kid that was allowed to have the
halftime points i can't skate transition
i don't
i'm a street skater i don't do vert okay
maybe big air
if it's available you're also not
invited get your bike and get out of my
yard
[Laughter]
hey listen take your roller blades and
hit the [ __ ] brick yeah yeah before
we start making playing target practice
with our bb gun oh
uh remember that one that same kid that
had the half pipe had the bb gun
shot my buddy somebody with the half
shot with a bb gun
shot him with a half pipe shot him with
a bb gun uh
yeah that was also that's where i almost
got my eye blown out with a firecracker
this kid's bad news now that i'm doing
the math
that's how it works it's never just one
thing no it's ever the parents
parents were never around the dad was
never around uh it was
never a house that you would ever in a
million years think about eating over
however that house always had the best
iced tea or
juice mix in the refrigerator because
there was no regulator on it there was
no regular
it was a pound of sugar yeah the iced
tea at that house out of the [ __ ]
plastic pitcher
would blow your hair back yeah and the
moment was probably done nine out of ten
times was pretty attractive
i don't know if i ever met this kid's
mom really that's what it was like
wow well he was friends with it he was a
neighbor of my friend so like
i we would you know it wasn't like a
direct line of contact
meeting the mom for the first time was
scary yeah
she could come home from work and lose
it yeah there was definitely houses
where like i spent a lot of time where
i'm like are there even do you have
parents
what the [ __ ] is going on in here that's
the type of crib where you see your
first broken bone
yeah yeah where you're like ah put it
back put it back put it back
your little faces of death going on the
vhs fantastic question
um all right this one's from a poppy too
sloppy ever call out of work because
you're too sunburned from the weekend
[Laughter]
talking about a july fourth question i
don't know but i'm gonna
yeah if i get a phone call on thursday
that you're too sunburned i'm gonna know
what's up
um that's a sigh i don't think
classy people get that burn
because they've done it before it's the
guy who's like i just got to get a good
base if you ever say i got to get a good
base you're trash because i say you got
to get a good base
one good burn let it sit in and then
mate and do some maintenance on it
again it comes with baggage it's not
just that one thing because there's a
good chance that you didn't just get
sunburned you went out and you got
[ __ ] hammered yes that's what i'm
saying
you're drunk so you're really not not
coming in because of the sunburn it's
because of the hangover
which now involves sunburn because
you're a bozo yes exactly
it's a it's a series of shitty mistakes
yes yeah yeah yeah but it's bad now
now's the time of year like you'll see
on like barstool people like posting
videos of dudes that are like
[ __ ] lobster right yeah yeah can you
get away with that can you
can you call out a work from sunburn i
don't know if i
i've been in a position i've had such
bad sunburn where i couldn't do anything
i go strap throat all the time that's my
number one excuse i got strep throat but
i've
yeah that's a big one that or pink eye
too oh yeah the pink guy they want a
picture
yeah you just do this i used to go in
the bathroom and just [ __ ] rub my eye
and come out like there's something
wrong with my eye and i used to work
holy [ __ ] yeah damn that's genius
yeah i never thought of that i would do
it and then like 10 minutes later go
back in you know so you're like building
a story you know what i mean like if
somebody sees you like oh your eyes
already i don't know i'm [ __ ] doing
blind myself i throw a thing a bleach in
your face
there's a party to there's a party
tonight starting at eight i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here i gotta say
mushing your finger in your eye is a
great way to get pink guy sure
in a public bathroom yeah for sure um
but then i would be like yeah my eye
itches or something and then they see it
and they go oh
[ __ ] you can't be [ __ ] bagging
people's groceries with pink eye
[ __ ] i'm like are you sure i'll stay
nah nah go
go don't touch nothing and get out pink
guy's gross man
i was petrified of that when i was a kid
i didn't want pink eye
no never a good look do either of you
ever have lice grown up
god damn write it twice we've talked
about this on the podcast that's insane
i don't think i've ever known anybody
with lice
well you know two people oh god
who have it now
yeah i had it twice once on the fourth
of july believe it or not oh wow
we last anniversary
i would have got you a bottle of lag of
volume 16 at least we uh
we were on our way we were on our way so
where were you three years ago
third anniversary we were on our way to
a uh a fourth of july party to watch the
fireworks at my dad's friend's house
somehow god damn it henry yeah he was so
pissed how to turn around drive back
we had to go right upstairs and burn the
car we had to go right upstairs and
start doing the comb my mom i don't even
know what that means
oh it's this fine comb that they ripped
the [ __ ] things out
my mom loved it she was up to like
ripping them out
brutal we're both crying he's downstairs
drinking alone
good times good times happy birthday
america
about as american as it gets right there
two little kids squawking upstairs yeah
um
hot dogs freedom headlights hot dogs
freedom and headlights
um this one uh this is just a home run
this is from regan
uh what is the crumb situation in your
gear shifter
i would say foley's probably got a six
piece and a small fry if i had to guess
i could make a pie out of what i got
there you kidding me
holy [ __ ] yeah that's so [ __ ] funny
that's
dead on damn that's good dude i remember
my mom my mom had a 98
sebring or a sebring convertible it's a
car i learned how to drive in
and dude there would be you could
probably get a small
fry out of from under the seats [ __ ] you
that would drop down and then you'd be
like looking for a quarter or something
dude pull out a proper whole french fry
from the car
it got worse i think with with our
generation having kids
because i remember when i was a kid we
it was monitored as far as like you know
you eating in the car what you spilled
but like you ever catch like a butter
yours that has a couple of kids now
and look in the back of his [ __ ]
minivan yeah holy it just
it reeks of old stale milk yeah it's
like a juice
yeah it's like goldfish everywhere just
flopping around
[ __ ] brewing look at that act out
thanks man yeah that was really nice
i didn't know what was doing a podcast
with sebastian
they got the goldfish everywhere um yeah
trash this one's from tk is it garbage
that have a black toilet
what like a lid no like the whole
toilet's black
i'm sure unless you're moving [ __ ]
weight or you're in or you're into
orgies
you're into group sex yeah uh yeah you
got a black light in your house
but then one of the comments if you have
a black toilet seat and thing that's
like you got that from a bar
if you have a white toilet if you have a
wiper yeah yeah that's industrial that's
commercial
you got that from a supply house you
didn't get that from [ __ ] from jet
road
yeah you didn't get that from home depot
you got that at ferguson what does it
have a urinal behind you um
uh but then one of the comments on
patreon was i've only seen it
in rich people's houses which i can too
attest to
yeah i picture like gold leaf mirrors
and all that
the whole wall is a mirror i know
there's a family friend of mine
um [ __ ] billionaire right
yeah proper billionaire yeah crazy you
um it's like it's not does he have a
nice piece of property it's a woman has
multiple nice pieces of bricks nice
piece of property
um so they they have a bathroom that's
all red patent leather floors walls and
ceiling
it's crazy what's patent leather like
like trademarked yeah patent-pending
leather
no it's like uh it's a leather it's like
do you ever like shoes some shoes are
patent leather
all right yeah i don't know how to
explain it's just like shiny leather but
it's cushioned
it's like it's [ __ ] it's crazy it's
gotta be like a [ __ ] knife not like
couch
like couch leather no like nice jordan
like jordans tend to be patently oh
air forces tend to be patently oh yeah i
know what you mean but like nice like
i don't i don't understand it sweet to
make sure not to do some triplets in
there
only number twos get an invoice for two
grand yeah
um the black toilet black toilets are
not cheap
that's i think it's a rich thing i think
it's a rich thing the cheapest one i'm
seeing is like 350.
you can get a white toilet at home depot
won't fit him not bad
um this one is just this is funny this
is from raw strain long time listener
but first question
you guys ever have one of the hottest
podcasts on the planet and still live
paycheck to paycheck
a matter of fact yes wait till you see
what we got in the works oh
man we're about to waste a lot of money
[Laughter]
i kind of i don't want to say whatever
no yes i know
ah that was a f i saw that one and it
hurt a little bit
we made a promise to ourselves that we
would
do the dumbest [ __ ] possible yeah we're
living this [ __ ]
we're living this baby yeah we're living
this and i had an idea yesterday that
it's
mind-blowing we're not going back to our
summer homes and reading hawthorne or
anything like that i don't know
we're keepers what you see is what you
get yeah damn thing
yeah patio i love it
uh all right this one's from jake uh
have you has anyone in your family ever
triggered a statewide amber alert
[Laughter]
on either side of the coin
i guess he said i think like i don't i
didn't uh copy but the comment was from
uh it was like his aunt took his
his kids on not whatever and everybody's
phone went off
wait his aunt his aunt took her kids
yeah
and wasn't supposed to type thing that's
a court thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah wow still that's
when they throw the net out there for
that
that's most of the times it's a family
member really yeah yeah yeah
last scene with father who's not allowed
to have him or whatever and what are
they splitting with the kid
that's the idea jesus go away for the
week now
you know what i just realized about
amber alerts is that the person the
kidnapper gets the alert too
it's like they got a police scanner now
they know the heat's on now they're
gonna tell them to duck down in the back
and [ __ ]
yeah but everybody knows that jeff it's
never like hey enough like
it's also to the car it's never like a
2021 lexus it's always like a [ __ ]
73 corolla you're like what the [ __ ]
it's never a nice car three tires no
steering wheel yeah
keep an eye out yeah no kidding uh
i just from isaac is it garbage to lick
your own blood off a cut or a scrape
i've done it for sure hundred percent
but
i can taste it i know the taste that
metallic taste yeah it's like [ __ ]
pennies in your mouth yeah
were you guys scab pickers what am i
yeah of course who isn't were you guys
i mean i wasn't in the [ __ ]
after-school club or anything but yeah
i dabbled i've definitely eaten a
scabbard
for being truthful here for being honest
chicken sandwich chicken sandwich
we can't be honest with ourselves i've
definitely eaten a scab
sure and and like peeled skin i've
definitely eaten that
as a young man
i don't have any scabs now kippy can we
get an official ruling
what's worse that foley ate growing up
dog food or
scabs scabs over the over the roll-on
deodorant
oh the deodorant was weird because it
was used that's the weirdest part to me
so the flavor comes from
[Laughter]
come on man oh man
oh yeah it's [ __ ] hard yeah i don't
know man it's all very not good
love peeling a scab love it
um get into it you're appealing too
early man that's a mess
we got a bleeder
in a couple of weeks um i this one's
from whit whiz
ever take a homemade sign to display at
a pro sports event
trash yeah i did it wrestling but
wrestling
that was the idea you did it at
wrestling i sh
what do you mean oh of course yeah come
on yeah
i was having a good time i wasn't at the
high school
go tony trying to get on sportscenter
yeah
um i saw one the other day was an
instagram it could have been a meme it
could have been a joke i don't know when
it was from
but it was a young hockey player i think
on the bruins or
um or on the penguins was skating by the
glass and there were these two girls
that's old yeah i blew you in college or
whatever you were in high school do you
remember us
the guy had a huge smile on his face
that's pretty funny that's from like
five or six years two smoke shows smoke
shows yeah yeah yeah
um yeah it's all about friends athletes
do all right
it's good stuff no never brought
anything like that
i don't even like wearing um
a hat or a [ __ ] jersey or anything
like that if i go to a game
not for not supporting the team it's
just that that then it's bose especially
if it's an away game
you can't do that away yeah home game of
hats okay yeah it's like you're just
asking for a fight
you got that kid from the suns tuning
you up on [ __ ]
sun's in four yeah the guy put you night
night
i make you take a [ __ ] dirt nap real
quick yeah no thanks
um let's see this one's from
raoul i think we've touched on this and
i've never done it ever go to a
breakfast buffet and stay for lunch or
dinner
it's dinner i mean what do you gotta do
i mean don't you have [ __ ] to do that
day
yeah hanging around no that's nuts to me
i pushed the envelope at a buffet i'll
tell you that
but never crossed over from meal to meal
yeah that's no but we've gotten that one
i'm not even joking we've gotten that
question probably
times fifth no i i've probably gotten it
50 times
like that's insane to me i would never
never a big buffet guy i think cause my
parents
huge buffet guy love it i think that's
the every restaurant should be a buffet
every russian i would be so down with
that oh would you really love that you
seem like a guy who has a lot of
self-control
i love the vibe i love the fact that
like you know
you shouldn't be eating there's hostage
there's no one judging you yeah i mean
no outside outside we're judging you you
can have your salad course you have your
pudding at the end yeah a crack house is
a judge-free zone too man
but we all know it's a cracker we all
know who's in there
yeah we never [ __ ] with him i think it
was just more of like uh you ever went
to the rosa
the rosa the ponderosa no i think it's
because my parents were like
super poor that it was like a thing in
their head of like we can't that was
like i told you they drew like weird
lines in the sand of like we're not
gonna do that and a lot of garbage
people do that of like
we're not them and i think that was
where they separated like oh you're them
sure i've been wanting to check out the
cece's pizza buffet
i have done that in state college
pennsylvania and
i was all banged up i went there after a
game sure rightly so
it was like you had to wait for whatever
you want you know they're like oh we got
the bacon will be out in six minutes
[ __ ] yeah that's gonna get you with
the prime rib at the buffet like oh the
prime rib is not done yet like you knew
what time you were opening yeah let's go
doors are open it should be pr yeah the
[ __ ]
the potatoes agratine already the prime
rib should be [ __ ]
up with the horseradish sauce um
yeah that was never i mean there was one
chinese buffet and my neighbor
like you know a couple minutes away that
i went to a handful of times but i was
always like
nah oh they do it right so good there's
one there's one off delaware ave
i mean the big man used to hit it oh man
good night
away from prying eyes on the cover of
darkness
but never stayed two meals um i feel
like that's something you do
with an obnoxiously large amount of
people like you have like
there's like eight of yous doing that
you take over a corner
you know one's bigger than the next the
kids are big i have no
kids are running around it's a tough
look i have no desire to ever see a lot
of spandex and dirty t-shirts i'm
imagining
yeah tough you'll never catch me in one
unless it's for content
and i hear they got good chicken fingers
other than that never get one
no um is it the honey mustard fountain
i was more of a barbecue man it's true
it's true folks
i always forget he did love barbecue um
i
was an adorable kid this one barbecue
sauce and cigarettes
couple of birdies just think that you
started smoking so young that there was
a time where your mom
like you were still like her little boy
and like probably like you want to be
honest and she probably like brought you
in for a hug one time and you smelled
like cigarettes
what do you think that did to her turned
her on
[Laughter]
rub a little absolutely she likes bald
guys who smell like marble lights
she's got a type um now
i don't know i mean i didn't for sure i
didn't start smoking at like 12.
i had smoked at 12. i wasn't [ __ ] i
wasn't buying packs
it's kind of whatever get your hands on
at that point steal a couple from the
old man
a sick break in between cartoons is
pause that real quick
it's also crazy i i used to see my dad
sings every now and then but would get
nervous
that like i'm like what if he counts
them and i'm like he doesn't count like
you know what i mean like who
a 12 year old would count his cigarettes
a [ __ ] 45 year old man who smokes two
packs a day isn't
i thought there was nine in here you
know what i mean there's only seven what
happened to the other two
you appreciate replace it with a
twizzler he ain't gonna know
put the candy cigarettes in there he's
on a job site
[Laughter]
i got kippy together good good it's good
stuff
yeah um
talk to me this is from chris uh ever
beerbong anything other than beer
i saw a kid do it freshman year of
college he was that
he was like right out of a [ __ ] do
not do this a college poster
thought he was a hot shot it's always
the hot shot real maverick
it was like the first friday night we
had been there for football camp so we
were a little bit seasoned we didn't
want to [ __ ] act like idiots but
these kids got their [ __ ]
first year of college acting someone
dies every every every
every [ __ ] first weekend and this kid
fondled like um
vodka or whatever no yeah exactly it was
like jameson and something else
and he had he had his room on the first
floor in these like nice dorm rooms
so he did that in the room we're like
what the [ __ ] we got out of there
we walked back [ __ ] like later on
that night and his window was open
it's a tough look when your windows open
like the windows just open
yeah and he's just on the floor [ __ ]
twirled up like a pretzel
so i had to go in there turn him on the
side make sure he wasn't dead check his
butthole
he was out of college within two weeks
yeah those guys don't last long in the
dorms
it's like yeah i gotta move to
off-campus housing and then it's like
you live in an apartment or whatever
yeah making it to class
you guys are literally describing me
yeah he's just
thinking to be thrown at a college or a
school
that's dude that's that's that's real
trash
not saying guys don't recover from it
and do good in life you bounce back yeah
i live in queens
that's true and we help them move so
you're not doing that
yeah now i was always good with not
getting caught
especially especially especially so i
was so much smarter than those [ __ ]
bozo security guards because
i went to the temple so there was like
proper security guards to keep out the
riffraff
black water relax no i'm just saying
there was like but
it wasn't just like somebody sitting at
a desk like it was like you scanned it
it was like a
short you know like there was metal
detectors involved no there was a metal
detector kippy's in the bushes with a
sixer and daddy light and some
night vision goggles
blue team go blue team go
i'm in an air duct with a 40.
no my trick was i would take a big
basket of dirty laundry
have two 30s in there and then just
stuff the dirty laundry on the sides
so you carry in a [ __ ] basket of
laundry wait they were checking your
[ __ ] in the dorm when you came in like
looking through your bag they could yeah
what yeah oh [ __ ] i mean they didn't
like i like i think like friday or shout
out to widener university in the 90s why
you last was like margaritaville
you got a beer helmet on yeah dude uh i
keep living i could go to wider
university and walk out with a degree in
six months
okay let us know where that goes so what
were we saying general studies
i like you graduated you don't know what
it takes either
i know what it takes and i ain't got it
okay i know what it takes and i
i don't have it wait did you just high
road me on getting kicked out versus
dropping out
then i hired you i don't know what that
means
exactly i mean that exchange
you were like getting kicked out to
tough look you got kicked out or you
stopped yeah no you might have been
asked to leave no you were
you were like proper kicked out like
they said you for
i was kicked out for academics like a
gentleman
just being an idiot you were kicked out
for [ __ ]
skateboarding over the dean's face or
something like that
whatever the [ __ ] you did no sliding his
bumpers yeah dude tape wasn't even the
camera it was [ __ ]
i'm talking about people that got in
trouble for [ __ ] if you flunk out like a
[ __ ] regular person
i got no problems that's why they
[ __ ] create a dental school you know
what i mean or whatever the [ __ ]
now you don't have dental insurance so
it's full circle i do have dental
insurance now actually all right thanks
for your sunday night
[ __ ] bozo i do
um feel the knives slowly coming out no
this has been a fun this has been a
[ __ ]
this has been a good jolly up uh i threw
the first shot you did
you always do what are you talking about
at t-bone whether you know it or you
don't you someone across the bow of the
boat
and you couldn't even get into weiner
and you couldn't get out
there's something right there you need
to apply to waden university oh let's
see if you get in
i don't slow down i'm so done i'm not
covering the eggs i'm not covering the
application
this is this is a personal thing tony
will not be paying for that
i think because i was a superior athlete
you're not going to get in
but we're going to do it um i
i did a beer bong one time in uh high
school
and third grade painkillers were bitter
pills were big back in the day
i'm listening some would say they're
pretty big now
[Laughter]
yeah but in my husband's big fan base
you're doing beer bongs with percocet
floaters yeah that's what happened
what well uh so um
i did hippies crazy i didn't do i wasn't
big on pills i didn't like
i just huge huge booze bag right big
boozer you weren't big on them what does
that mean
i i i i'm not big on little debbies but
i dabble well i'm allergic to i'm
allergic to most painting i'm allergic
to
hydrocodeine and hydrocodone yeah loser
how about this guy so um
i uh so whatever so i just never [ __ ]
with him i'm like i'm allergic to it too
man
turns me into the life of the party
i break out in good times
doctor said i'm becoming too rad
i want me to go to they want me to have
an intervention
i mean rehab for being too [ __ ] cool
gotta slow this guy down huh bit the
[ __ ]
man trying to stop me holy [ __ ] no i so
i just
all everybody was doing them they were
huge in school and that because this was
at the time when the pills hit
and there was no real regulation of them
this was this is what started the opium
epidemic yeah that that hit your [ __ ]
squad like the first wave at norman
yeah they did they didn't see it coming
so i mean dude we're doing him at school
like
like there was like friends because they
were you didn't have to [ __ ] look for
him back then they were giving him out
you [ __ ] pull a toenail doc's got
[ __ ] 30 school bus
dude up in your driveway the [ __ ] uh
oh this is nuts i don't even think i
don't even know if i ever told you this
foley was jumping school buses like evil
knievel
the yellow school bought the perk 10s
they were called the yellows they called
school buses back in the day
um the yellow perk tens and i didn't i
mean
and also it's like we're making light of
this i have lost like i mean so much so
many
so many people have died of course did i
know of this it's horrible but
they were all going around super [ __ ]
crazy uh
and like it we knew [ __ ] pharmacists
that were in on it they ended up going
to jail but like pharmacists were like
being like oh here's like you know the
bottle that you fill the bottles with
i'm aware like the big like it looks
like a bottle like creatine or whatever
somebody had one of those muscle
relaxers at a party we used to call that
the ark of the covenant
[Laughter]
never looked directly into it yeah so
burn your face off
a big somebody had a big thing of muscle
relaxers of those and i showed up to the
party late
and everybody was [ __ ] doing muscle
relaxation
what the [ __ ] they do i mean they we we
round
around okay what are you guys doing
tonight huh a couple six-packs huh
chasing around the girls
wait around we ran with a wonky crew if
he's just losing a twister like what's
going on
yeah everybody's all rubber banded
everyone just hooked up to an iv
sitting around um so i got there late
and i'm like oh i got to play ketchup
right
so somebody was hoping how you do if you
want to look cool
so somebody was holding your pressure
somebody was holding a beer bong
and i was like oh i'll do that like yo
that's for me like joking i was out for
me
and they were like no it's for [ __ ]
steve or whoever i'm like oh [ __ ] steve
and i grabbed it and i did it
and i didn't know steve liked to party
apparently
cause steve has steve had a couple of
fights just for visual
kevin was 33 years old when this took
place steve had a couple like this exact
for me
steve had a couple of kickers in this
thing and uh
i didn't know so i keep drinking and
then you know whatever an hour or two
and
my buddy's ago i'm going to wawa to get
some food or something like i'll go with
and there was kippy's doing yoga in the
driveway
this gets loose i'm blowing myself
i mean there's never seen a guy eat his
own butt before sucking my own dick
i'm on the coffee table like [ __ ]
circus olay or whatever the [ __ ] it is
gimpy
i'm painted blue
so we're in the car and i remember there
was cops at the wawa so we couldn't pull
up
so we pull into a neighborhood to let
the fuzz you know let the heat cool down
can't show up but and this is when it
hit me my buddy's like
there was nothing more terrifying than
knowingly walking into a
convenience store in high school all
[ __ ] up and hear a [ __ ]
hear a walkie-talkie in the distance
it's like jurassic park with the raptors
clever girl there's two at the end of
the ship aisle
girl pops up from behind the hot dog if
he comes through the chips
and nature finds a way that's my gold
bloom
um so yeah
so he's i apparently he he realized i
was super [ __ ] up and i was
the cop or the boy my boy because we
were like parked in a neighborhood like
across the street waiting for him to
leave
yeah you had your ankles behind your
head you were in the front seat and the
back seat
stretched out like a laffy taffy in a
hot car
this kid's on screw balls and i remember
looking
at my buddy and he was laughing at me
because apparently like i was just like
all [ __ ] up and i look over at him and
he's going and like
i in turn what i see is
i'm like oh this thing there was [ __ ]
where's steve at i think i got a bad
dude and dose couldn't move my hot dose
of coors light my arms felt like
i'm like yeah and then i was i don't
remember getting to the wawa
that was the end of the [ __ ] old uh
very dangerous stuff children yeah don't
[ __ ] with it i mean
obviously i want to be sincere we make a
lot of light of it but like what the
[ __ ] i mean yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
horrible um
all right let's switch gears here we
took uh i opened up
what from the huge bottle of muscle
relaxers
i think our gears are just fine my
friend
no so i uh i opened up on uh instagram
and twitter i said you know it's a
little fun thing
tweet me because so many people tag us
and stuff and tweet stuff as i was like
yo
you know dm us okay dm us the trashiest
thing in your house right now
sure let's see where we stand you know
what i mean
so i i pulled uh a handful and this
might be a thing we do you know in the
future but like so many people send us
[ __ ] that i want to [ __ ] you know
i want to spotlight some of the real
[ __ ] trish we got
oh yeah you know what i mean i love it
all right let's see
um let's start off with a little
appetizer if you catch my drift
a starter a starter dirt balls out there
um
this guy has a bench press in his living
room
holy [ __ ] single guy probably
i would [ __ ] hope that's not a family
affair it looks like a detective
you have some some that looks like some
home goods aren't
hanging up there yeah that's not [ __ ]
uh and that ain't new that bench press
that
that thing no
man that guy's definitely fighting some
demons in there
it's like a scene out of donnie brass
there's a half a bottle of scotch
sitting on that coffee table that he has
at night
yeah and a revolver with one bullet also
he's got a he's got like a nightstand as
a table in his lip that nightstand
that's a nightstand in the corner right
there
oh all the way in the corner with the
plants on top yeah yeah right there
that's bad that doesn't match the motif
no
of single dad that's fantastic um this
one's also pretty bonkers
they got a [ __ ] carpet on the wall
carpet on the wall what's that about i
don't know
now if it's just a piece of rug isn't
that classy
that prince not that classy ah that
could be some
i think it look it looks like a basement
i'm hoping it's a basement
tapestries are classy this is tapestry
yeah isn't a rug just a ta isn't a
tapestry just a rug hanging on the wall
well i don't know i think it is that's a
tapestry
i'm not sure but that's not
the cordless phone right now cordless
phone in the can of febreze you got
ain't a [ __ ] great look
at that tough look you gotta fabrize
your wall
ah maybe the carpets are smells could be
a couple of pet stains on that thing you
gotta whack it every once in a while
that's a tough look man
no good this one this is a bedroom that
is this gets
this is getting into the bonko-esque fan
base we got here
okay this is someone's bedroom that they
sent us
what the [ __ ] you see that how many
dressers there's one
two three four dressers
and uh two strange office cabinets yeah
that's i mean
yikes look at that wow that's a tough
look i think that's a
[ __ ] stuffed they got a sega stuffed
animals is that a computer on top of the
whatever that thing is what here now on
the other side
right there here no on the white cabinet
a computer is that a computer no what is
here
yeah those are storage bins good lord i
mean they got
they got a [ __ ] they got like
[ __ ] two foot tall south park those
are undies hanging in the corner there
aren't they
there's some undies right here woohoo is
panties hanging over the line
all right change my tune real quick
a-okay in my book
i would lose most of that cabinets and
spin and get some get some space in
there
walk there's no floor space yeah you got
to get rid of some of that [ __ ] you need
to go minimalistic you can't have that
many clothes too yeah clean that [ __ ] up
will you
this is a soundcloud listener if i've
ever seen one
they're not on a patreon um this is
[ __ ] banana this is in someone's
house
right let's see it they got an exit sign
in your house dude i don't know that's
pretty sweet and it's all
tricked out no it's not tricked out he
said they taped it because it's
you can see the exit light so they put
electrical tape
over the red light so they can't see it
your house shouldn't have an exit sign
wait why'd they cover it up because they
don't want it to be glowing the red glow
i would want it to be glowing okay well
they don't oh you mean that was in there
when they moved in
yeah this isn't like a kitschy thing
this is i thought it was like when you
had a traffic light in your
room at different at college which would
still be trash no
this is a functional exit sign in their
apartment
what do you live on a government base
dude it's got the flood lights on it too
man that thing's going off yikes that's
a tough one holy [ __ ]
that's like you live in a you live in
like a retail store or something
this guy's lives under marshalls yeah
yikes
um all right let's do uh this one's
actually very classy so this is this was
really cool
this is uh this is a filing cabinet
right nice filing
nice violent cabinet flicker and some
records on top with a cactus
very nice right very classy very classy
let's [ __ ] open her up he's got a
[ __ ] bar in there
damn he's got a drop sync in there
he's got the glasses got it all set up a
drop
sink that sinks in there yeah but
there's no running water no but it's for
ice probably for the party you got the
glasses right there
okay yeah okay i like it that's classier
than anything you got
yeah i'll give you that it's classier
than anything i got classier than the
[ __ ] uh exit sign i could tell you
that much
dude that exit sign is a tough [ __ ]
look
um this one i think you would like uh
this is a collection of fortune cookies
they keep in
in the [ __ ] in the kitchen
i'll tell you what the fruit basket the
top shelf of the fruit basket is a
fortune cookie has a snack
ain't too shabby i get too superstitious
with them i feel like
i have to you're eating people's dreams
yeah well
i can never have one unless i had it
unless i had chinese food
that's your super yeah and you have to
read the thing before you throw it out
otherwise it's bad luck
okay um this one just came in right
before we started recording this is a
[ __ ]
i mean a definition of a tough look
this is a fridge with duct tape on the
shelves
paint duct tape nonetheless that's
painter's tape man
i think that might be docked that's
terrible that's a [ __ ]
big beer's in half and half on the
[ __ ] shelves yeah
man pink duct tape holding the fridge
together this is my fridge in the
kitchen at my apartment in the burbs and
you know how that got that way
that was that somebody slammed the [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ]
argument yeah yep because it's both
things are going yup that don't just
happen
now yeah no you gotta that's after one
too many schlitzes
yup or nutty irishman no coffee
um this one brings up a few things that
i want to mention
so he's got a hole in his
wall that goes outside that he's covered
with a license because the squirrels
will get in there
the squirrels look it in there yeah so
he's covered with a license plate you
got to watch around those window ac
units
anyway squirrels will [ __ ] eat right
through that [ __ ] but the trashiest
thing to me is they got
i feel this is trash you know i like to
pass it to the band the gentleman from
bluebell
the built in the wall like they've cut
the wall out that's not in the window
that ac unit is in the wall that's a
tough
do you see what i'm saying that's a
year-round ac unit that's
through brick wood drywall
wow and it'll i mean the thing's beat up
it's not even a new area
the question is what do they cover that
with in the winter to keep the cold out
you know it's like a blanket or
something like that yeah it's i mean
another air conditioner i don't know
that's trash that's a tough look
straight drywall to outside
come on i don't know
some insulation in there little aluminum
panther or something
screams florida panhandle could be
connecticut license plates connecticut i
mean i don't think these
i mean these people can get their hands
on a license plate i think do you think
they don't know the way around long-term
parking
we've talked about license plate
collection
yikes yeah um all right let's see
we have uh two more here um this one is
just like what the [ __ ]
uh there's a toilet in the closet holy
[ __ ] a used broken toilet they've kept
in their closet
oh my god oh it's not connected no
oh okay which i don't know what's worse
i think if it was connected it would be
all right well
that's what i'm saying well shout out to
get rid of that man what are you doing
clean that closet out
jesus looks like toby's place
what kind of dumps are you taking if
you've got to have a backup toilet on
deck
also why why did great in the first
place probably expensive toilet it
wasn't black
no but it was gray it wasn't white it
wasn't white get that on facebook market
share
um it's called marketplace is that what
it is
it's what it is get it on there too um
all right this will be the last one here
this
is [ __ ] the the last guy in this guy
could get together and figure something
out
this guy's got a do you see he fixed his
toilet
is that flex seal with flex seal whoa
see that
get that to the [ __ ] producers of the
infomercial
also he so he fixed his crack toilet
with flex seal and he's got the blue
water which is a [ __ ]
tough wow look man he's living it right
there that got that dude
shout out to flex seal though i wonder
if he did it while the toilet was filled
productive flexion can solve anything it
really can gotta get some of that in
here
yeah somebody send us some flexibility
fill in your belly button
[Laughter]
no water that's awesome that was fun it
was fun so we'll do that
i'm coming yeah submit some pics and
we'll you know we'll pick out of the
best and we'll do it every you know
maybe the family episodes or show you
know some guests or whatever we'll
figure it out
that was great i mean also too these
flooded in this is like the fir like the
best 10 i took but i mean
we had like 100 submissions in like 10
minutes that's awesome yeah
gang we love you uh this has been
another exciting episode thank you so
much for tuning in
kippy got anything for them guys uh
first of all check uh
check me out at cameron comedy on all
social media then follow the ru garbage
pages
uh there's ru garbage on instagram and
twitter uh we post links you know if you
don't follow we post
uh clips from the live shows clips from
the pod stuff like that
we're also starting at clips channel uh
the link will be in the description to
this on youtube we'll be posting you
know
four five six seven eight minute clips
on youtube to help spread the word a bit
uh and that's it check out a [ __ ]
live show we'll be in columbus
and cleveland oh yeah um real soon next
week
this week when this go no next week yeah
next week uh next
uh july 14th and 15th and those tickets
are actually [ __ ] moving which i
wasn't expecting let's go so let's get
some [ __ ] tickets let's go
and we'll see you check out the tour
dates in the link we love you guys we'll
see you next week